اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين
كولونا اعطي انتهاء مع عرف بازمه
التاشيرات مع المغرب وقالت عقب مباحثات
اجرتها في الرباط مع نظيرها المغربي نصر
بريطانيا ان الرئيس امانويل ماكرو سيقوم
بزياره للمغرب في الربع الاول من العام
القادم
[موسيقى]
لارجاع وضع النشاط القنصلي الى طبيعته
العاديه ويمكنني ان اضيف تم الامر ومن ثم
الجواب على السؤال المطروح نعم بشكل واضح
تم حول الموضوع وانهائه
من جهته دعا وزير الخارجيه المغربي ناصر
البوريطه فرنسا لتجديد علاقاتها مع بلاده
في ظل وجود تحديات مشتركه وقال ان البلدين
يعملن على احياء اليات التعاون والتنسيق
المختلفه
مغربيه فرنسيه السيده الوزيره اوضح ذلك
هناك حاجه الى اعاده احياء هذه العلاقه
المغرب وتغير داخليا وايضا تم موقعه
خارجيا وسياقل الاقليمي والعالم والتغير
فرنسا كما قالت السيده الوزيره تغيرت وهذه
العلاقه لا يمكن ان تبقى هكذا مع الاحتفاظ
باسوس للعلاقه المتينه يجب الاخذ بعين
الاعتبار هذه التطورات وكما قلت مغرب قوي
داخليا وخارجيا مع تنوعا في الشركاء ليس
عائقا امام التطور للعلاقات بين البلدين
بل على العكسين من ذلك